für dieses Gericht hast du garantiert
nicht alle Zutaten zu Hause aber fangen
wir einfach an ich habe hier ein
Rumpsteak dass ich in Streifen Schneide
wichtig gegen die Faser Richtung
schneiden das nehmen wir jetzt alles
geben ist in eine Schüssel dunkle
Sojasoße helle Sojasauce sesamölin MSG
und Backpulver das Rezept ist von canji
Lopez old wenn man das ganze schön
einmassiert und ordentlich knetet dann
macht das Backpulver dieses Steak
unglaublich zart neben unserem beef
brauchen wir auch noch den gehen wir
jetzt geschnitten in unsere Wokpfanne
mit heißem Wasser so gehen wir den
Deckel drauf dünstens ein bisschen vor
und kümmern uns um die Soße für unseren
Soße so ja Soße dunkle Sojasoße Mirin
und Zucker alles verrühren dazu gehört
noch ein bisschen soßenbänder an ja
jetzt ist alles vorbereitet die Fahne
ist verdammt heiß wir geben das Fleisch
hinein wenn das Fleisch fast durch ist
geben wir ingwer und Knoblauch dazu
raten das mit an und jetzt kommt unsere
Soße zum Einsatz die wir einfach
dazugeben Brokkoli kommt dazu und uns
ein bisschen einzudecken gebe ich
vorsichtig ein bisschen Soßenbinder dran
wunderbar schöne Konsistenz